je te pose une question est une fait un
chantage à chaque fois chantal quel est
ton salaire dans les grosses têtes sur
rtl
qu'est ce c'est votre faute j'aimerais
pas malade et ses intimes d'anne d'un
salaire allez on passe à la limite je
parle jamais d'argent je déteste ça
chantal si tu devais tromper michel avec
un animateur télé ce serait qui et toi
avec l'animatrice de chez toi allez lui
fasse moi ce serait la belle toi c'est
toi ce sera avec l animateur avec toi
d'abord à bâle aura franchement reflète
un petit peu avant l'émission suite
arrêter d'embaucher d'ailleurs sachant
thales que pour toi emmanuel macron est
un bon président oui formidable
extraordinaire jamais le dirait des vols
d'un président magnifique comme ça même
si j'en ai envie
plus il adore les fans du chanteur
quelle a été ta plus gros comptes au
public alors la famille coffe ou la
méchante et moi comment ça s'appelle
cette science en bande organisée en
valeur je veux dire on avait préparé les
interviews et chantal à tout casser on
va pas se mentir à la toupie c'est au
fond plus pénible normal c'est déjà très
bien
je posais des questions el bendir je te
réponds que si tu fais ça je ne réponds
à cela que c'était en écosse sont en
revanche en salle et je connais pas du
tout merci c'est alors retenu que le
chantage le plus pourri avec kelly
morris tu t'entends le mot ya pas
vraiment démarré c'était qui je
m'entends tu pas les fréquentent pas
d'accord nous font chier je la dois
cette pâte